[Musique]
deux jours
pas de défilé cette année encore pour
célébrer le 14 juillet compte tenu du
contexte sanitaire mais une cérémonie
était tout de même organisé ce mercredi
matin au jardin de l'état
c'est la fête nationale nous l'avons
fait dans un cadre sécurisé l'an dernier
nous avons reproduit dans cette
organisation
cette année dans les jardins de l'état
post est important qu'on puisse tous se
retrouver et en parler avec les uns et
les autres je crois que tout le monde
était était heureux de pouvoir célébrer
la fête nationale dans ses jardins de
l'état en 2021
après des moments éprouvants de les
rappeler dans nos locaux dans mon
allocution des moments difficiles que
nous avons connus que nous connaissons
encore parce que la crise sanitaire est
toujours et toujours présente et c'était
aussi bien sûr l'occasion de saluer de
rendre hommage
tous ceux qui concourent à la sécurité
des réunionnaises et des réunionnais les
forces armées
les gendarmes les policiers les pompiers
et je souhaitais vraiment rendre un
nouvel hommage à nos soignants passer
ces hommes et ces femmes de devoir qui
se battent au quotidien pour nous pour
notre santé au programme de cette
matinée la cérémonie militaire suivie de
la cérémonie républicaine dommage avec
la remise de décorations et deux
médailles une année placée sous le sceau
de l'espérance en promouvant les valeurs
d'engagement de la jeunesse réunionnaise
j'ai bien noté donc dans le discours
notamment du préfet combien la jeunesse
a été mise en avant
cette jeunesse réunionnaise conquérante
qui chaque jour nous rappelle que
lorsque nous sommes dans nos activités
dans nos missions
eh bien nous devons l'accompagner parce
que au delà des difficultés sanitaires
il ya aussi bien sûr l'avenir de la
france de notre nation et l'avenir de
notre département
le message adressé à notre jeunesse a
été fort et le message aussi aux
artistes puisque nous avons vu beaucoup
d'artistes participer à cette cérémonie
c'est là aussi donc une façon de dia à
ce monde qui souffre de la crise
sanitaire qu' on ne peut pas l'oublier
l'année dernière ce sont les soignants
qui avaient été mises en avant
et cette année eh bien les artistes
réunionnais bravo très belle cérémonie
parmi ces artistes lucas maillots aux
lauréats du concours de slam organisée
par la collectivité départementale
moi ça me fait plaisir de nous pour
représenter le même temps qu'il ya deux
ans et qui a passé plus d'émotion à
travers le monde texte d'un l'honneur
oui parce que des gens j'étais invité
par le préfet directement donc
ça change un petit peu une belle
cérémonie pour commémorer la prise de la
bastille en 1789 symbole de fin de la
monarchie absolue
[Musique]